la lumière est verte tout va bien la
valeur limite de 8 100 ppm n'a pas été
atteinte ce capteur a été installé mi
janvier dans cette cantine de l'école
saint-exupéry magny les hameaux a fait
le choix des capteurs de co2 dans des
lieux communaux ça nous permet
d'accompagner
on va dire la la sécurité sanitaire
dans dans les lieux en priorité ou les
enfants ne porte pas de masque dans
notre
système éducatif et de garde et garde
des enfants on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'endroits qui sont
propices au développement
vu qu vide pas que commandé début
décembre les vins capteur se trouvent
principalement dans les réfectoires et
salle d'activités il mesure la charge en
co2 émettent un signal sonore et un
signal lumineux en cas de forte
concentration c'est venu nous
directement
en observant un petit peu ce qui nous
est dit au niveau scientifique
et puis on voyait aussi que dans le
domaine scolaire il ya un certain nombre
de demandes des personnels vis-à-vis de
leur employeur il ya vie l'éducation
nationale on voyait qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de retour de l'appareil de
gassion nationale voilà nous entende
communaux en nos responsabilités coût
environ une centaine d'euros par
capteurs la chaille pour le moment 100 %
financés par le budget communal une
demande de financement a été déposée
auprès de l'état